[Music]
and i got this video from a friend the
other day that was fascinating and it's
all about the newer generations the
younger generations gen z and the
relationship to cash now we say cash is
king around here but there's a new
slogan for gen z cash is free
i'm not this
i know it sounds like an oxymoron so
we're going to play the video and we'll
get your reaction okay
the other day i was out and i made a
purchase at a store
and the
gen z person who was checking me out
said that'll be 18 something and i
pulled out of my purse at 20 and i gave
her the 20 and i said i just have cash
and she said oh wow that's like it's
then it's like free
and i said oh what do you mean and she
said well if you pay with cash it's free
and i said
i don't know what you mean
and she said well like if you have a
five dollar bill and you buy a coffee
for 4.98 it's like a free coffee it's
like it doesn't count cashes it doesn't
count it's not real money
and
i was very confused by this so
i came home and both of my kids are gen
z and i asked them both
what was she talking about and my
daughter who is 18 said yeah cash
doesn't count if you have cash it
doesn't count it's not like it's real
money the real money is what's in your
debit
on your debit card
is this true
is this true i love this love her energy
there she's just as confused as all of
us that is so funny it raises an
interesting question okay
so here's my get here remember
my like knee-jerk
reaction so when we say around here cash
is king
yes actual cash um is part of that but i
also under that say like but you're it's
your money like part of that is meaning
you have the money to pay for something
so whether that's money in a bank
account or that is money you tangibly
have in your hand
the idea is yes debt is dumb
cash is king cash is
your money yes and but studies have a
layer deeper studies have shown that you
spend 12 to 18 percent less
when you spend
actual cash you feel the pain because
you feel the pain you're letting them go
of your own money um
versus a debit card i think is a little
bit different but versus a credit card
where you have no emotional attachment
because you know i'm just going to pay
it you know i'm going to try to pay it
at the end of the month and there's time
and i'm fine you know there's just no
big emotion there
so all that to be said uh i like that
they at least said
that what's in your checking account is
what counts and i'm like is it because
you can track it like if you
you know if i swipe my debit card i have
to track that transaction for me in
every dollar or if you go on your online
bank statement you see it shows up even
though it's already been paid yeah it's
there so i guess their feeling is
once it's gone it's gone and it's not
traceable anymore and it feels freer
generations they grew up in a digital
world for sure for sure yes they're not
used to actually having
cash i thought she was gonna i thought
if the tick tock was gonna go to that
that she didn't know how to make change
or something she had never seen cash
like i thought it was going but it's
funny that it could also be true
you know it didn't even feel real and
okay
there's a part of me that i i kind of
small part i get it yeah i had some cash
um i don't even know what it was from
but it was in my purse
and i went scholatsky's is that like a
national chain yeah sandwich chain
schlosskies shallots because it's so
good
so i went through and i and i paid ten
dollars you know i was like it was it
was like nine whatever and i paid ten
dollars i was like okay i won't have to
track that in my every dollar app like
it's not gonna show up on my bank stay
like rachel's admitting it felt free
because that money in my purse was not
saying oh this is my cat this is my food
envelope like i didn't have an intention
for that ten dollar bill i don't even
know where it came from really yeah does
that make sense like so it did kind of
fee i get the feeling even though it's
really funny to say out loud i love that
it sounded like you were buying
something on the dark web and you were
just buying a sandwich
sandwich
is that how i set it up i haven't even
heard that restaurant name since like
1994. i love that rachel's still holding
oh and number one without black olives
all day rachel's keeping it alive what
do you think what do you think yeah my
take is this i don't think gen z has any
real reason to handle cash and so when
they do get it it's usually a gift from
a relative that's right it's from a
birthday it's from christmas you know
their paychecks are direct deposited and
then they use their card and they never
have to physically touch cash and when
they do have it they go well that was
from a gift and so it didn't really feel
like it's bonus money yes so i can use
this more frivolously that's fair and
that's how i see it okay i'm gonna keep
going because i'm like but then on the
other side all the cash stuffing went
nuts like last month yes where they were
actually cashing out their paychecks and
doing the envelope system they call it
cash stuffing stuffing this folder it's
a new trend that's been around yes since
like
so some of them are embracing this cash
life and love it because they realize
how responsible you can be with it we're
on the other opposite end it doesn't
even feel like money to them yeah well
and when you see cash now it's like whoa
that's a lot of money because you don't
see money anymore i know and so it's an
interesting uh you know conversation how
do you feel if you were just if ten
dollars just showed up in your wallet
and you can't remember how it got there
i see it and you went
got a number one without my columns
how would that would you feel like it
would feel a little bit like bonus money
yeah i wouldn't feel like obligated to
go deposit that in my bank account and
then budget for that i'll go okay sweet
i got 10 bucks from wherever sure
uh so so here's my thing if that's you
and you feel that way and you want to
get control of your money go deposit it
into your bank account you can do that
at atms i know they're like what do i
even do with cash you can put it into
the bank that's amazing but if you do
that then it's on your debit card and
you can budget for it you know with
every dollar and all that and even with
every dollar there's simple ways you can
still budget 200 for groceries
and then cash that out into an envelope
and actually spend that cash and track
it yes yes so it's still possible you
don't get an excuse to not budget
because you use cash absolutely yes and
the intentionality and actually it is
very helpful when you're intentional
with cash and you do something like the
envelope system it does help because you
physically you see
okay i only have this much money left
and out to eat or the you know i mean it
has a purpose yes
you know i'm a frugal guy rachel so
here's where i use cash every two weeks
i get my hair cut and my barber has a
five dollar discount if you pay with
cash oh and you do it and i do the cash
discount
so i always need to have cash on hand
how much do you pay how much you pay
will you i'll tell i'll tell america how
much i pay it's 35
wow that's really good george i thought
you were going to be way more boozier
than that no and i'm frugal you know me
rachel i'm always trying to do this oh
the hair is great tip i tip okay make
sure you tip your barbers okay
for sure so there we go cash is still
king even in 2022 ginzi you hear me it's
not free money budget for it get control
of it this is the ramsay show